someone I used to work for had a saying
that it was if it doesn't pass the taste
test it's probably going too good to be
true I think a lot of people that come
here they come from somewhere else
that's maybe you can trust people a
little more I have so what's your advice
to people that come here that have great
intentions and then they think that
other people are great intentions
because we often project our own stuff
onto other people yeah how do you be
protective without being too jaded old
too cynical or is it not awesome yeah I
think you just I think you just have to
learn like I think and here's here's the
thing about Hollywood dirt this is a
creative community at its core and at
the end of the day that leads people to
believe on the one hand that ordinary
business principles do not apply which
obviously they do if you've ever managed
a theater or managed a touring company
or worked in comedy or worked in music
and had to produce a band you know that
you just you need to have your business
in order you need to understand supply
and demand and and the basic principles
of professionalism and and there's a lot
of misconception about whether or not
basic professionalism is the law of the
land here which in fact it is and on the
flip side of it Hollywood is the most
well-heeled creative community on the
planet there is it's a circle in trees
biggest export there's more money here
than there is anywhere else in America
and there's more money here than there
is you know probably you know in any
other creative community on the planet
so it attracts people of all stripes and
when you take those two factors the
misconception about common sense and
then all that greed and you pile them in
one messy pile you're going to find
you're going to find yourself in some
dicey situations inevitably and I think
what it takes is just the practice of
exercising Iran professionalism coming
to the place where you understand that
the fundamentals that you learned
in theater or in wherever you came from
those basic fundamentals of conducting
your business and conducting your art in
a professional way will in fact just
take care of everything you know but you
have to learn the listening skills and
you have to learn the poise and the
groundedness to exercise those practices
from a place of balance and that's
there's no other way to do that but just
to throw yourself into it I think you
know so it's just trial and error and
learning not to get knocked over not to
get overwhelmed when someone comes at
you with a barrage of what appears to be
good news or a barrage of what appears
to be bad news and to learn to just
stand there in the eye of the storm and
hear what they're actually saying and to
choose and to ask the right questions
also due diligence finding out who's who
using your sense of the language and
using your sense of professionalism to
test them and ping them and see where
that where the argument falls apart
that's just something I learn on the fly
I think
you